JD told me I sleep paralysis I asked him
about it he said uh-uh like for two
seconds here awake but to tamper your
body I think he has day time paralysis
well that might be true you think that's
why he talks like that can you describe
it I mean honestly in a serious way I've
never really heard of this so I'm yeah
I'm laying there and I like wake up but
my mind is awake and I know I'm your
eyes open no my eyes are closed and and
and I can't move like I'm still sort of
dreaming a little bit but I'm awake and
I just can't move and you say you try to
will your body out of bed and you can't
move any part of yeah sometimes I can
like feel myself like slowly moving or
whatever and then all of a sudden I'm
able to jolt and told myself you know
awake don't jolt yeah do you get scared
of course because sometimes like it's a
you have a hard time breathing or I have
a hard time breathing - oh yeah a JD
puppy do you ever do absolutely price
III went out for a virus and I'm worried
that the mice are gonna chew through my
pajamas or I won't be able to shoo them
away
so in other words JD huh I mean JD JD
you feel vulnerable at that moment cuz
you can't protect yourself of course
yeah someone someone said that if you
try to blink like you're guilty you'll
wake up but that hasn't worked so far I
tried coming in my pants that didn't
work either this will happen to you now
that you're married and yeah I mean it's
not a regular thing but consistent
enough that you know it yeah I noticed
what's going on by the way JD and his
wife are going on another wine tour in a
few weeks if you want a JD update I've
heard this through the grapevine
no don't pun intended JD now that you've
visited several wineries can you
recommend a good white wine for the
people in our audience a good white wine
I mean I love a Riesling
I like this kung fu girl recent a lot
turns blue girl 20 construing I gotta
look it up I think that's why it's
called kungfu girl Riesling yes let me
double-check that Riesling is a sweet
wine is it not it is a sweet wine yes
very good
doesn't have to be sweet they're dry
Riesling other we could you to the ones
I like
[Laughter]